[Music]
this summer marks the fourth solo
appearance of chris hemsworth and thor
love and thunder as the first trailer
has unfortunately still not been
released fans are still waiting for
first real glimpse of the film's villain
gore though godbutcher now thanks to an
action figure we get a sneak peek of
gore's outfit in the movie even without
a trailer in a tweet from mcu direct on
april 10th the antagonist is seen with
bare feet and dressed in a wide row next
to him there's a huge sword that is
described as a strange and terrifying
weapon another leak shows all the major
figures of the upcoming film including
gore again here however he is seen on
the package not with white rope but a
dark one which fits better with a comic
original but instead he has no tentacles
but a normal nose the printed
descriptions on the back of the toy
boxes also reveal more about the
upcoming movie let's talk about the
valkyrie queen and the protection of her
people from new threats which of course
refers to gore it's a pity that there is
still no first trailer for thought for
love and thunder but we are confident
that time will come soon the movie will
be released in theaters on july 8th 2022
fans were amazed when vim diesel
recently announced the signing of mcu
star brie larson for the upcoming fast
and furious 10. after jace mamoa and
daniella melchior she is the next top
class newcomer for the second to last
part of the series and there's already a
theory about who she might play by a
range of forums and comment columns fans
are discussing larson's yet to be
announced row and many are of the
opinion that she will star as brian's
sister following the then also
unexpected news of john cena in an honor
roll it turned out that he would be
playing dumb's brother jacob so the
assumption of the announcement of
another close family member is not too
far-fetched besides a tribute to the
late paul walker's character in the
upcoming two films is considered certain
so it could make perfect sense to
introduce his sister apart from larsen
momoa and melchior we will of course see
old familiar faces such as vin diesel
tyrese gibson michelle rodriguez
ludacris and others again fast and
furious 10 is scheduled for release on
may 19 2023
we only recently reported that hollywood
legend bruce willis will no longer
perform in films and series due to
health problems just a few days later
jim carrey who had his big breakthrough
as a comedian and actor in the 90s also
announced that sonic 2 will probably be
his last movie before retiring in an
interview with access hollywood he
affirmed that he was quite serious about
it and that he loved his quiet life he
also added that he had already done
enough which is an extremely rare
statement from the ranks of a-list
actors one may surely granted him on a
personal level after all jim carrey is
nothing less than an icon in the field
of comedy still sonic fans in particular
wondering how his big role as dr
robotnik will continue this question has
also been addressed by those responsible
paramounts in sonic the hedgehog and its
recently released sequel introduced the
sonic cinematic universe alongside sonic
the hedgehog 3 his spin-off series about
sonic's companion knuckles is also in
the works even if jim carrey were to
return to the camera in a few years it
is clear that he will be taking an
extended break beforehand and thus will
not be available for the filming of
sonic the hedgehog 3. for sonic
producers neil h moritz and toby asher
it's at least evident that carrie's dr
robotnik would not be cast with anyone
else but him we are definitely excited
to find out what happens next with dr
robotnik and sonic the hedgehog 3.
unfortunately a release date for the
upcoming movie is not yet known
soon the sixth season of the breaking
bad spin of better calls all will be
coming to netflix this series centered
around the quirky lawyer saul goodman is
a total success and has been a
standalone part of the franchise
alongside the main series for years as
has now been announced on twitter there
will be a much anticipated reunion with
walter white jesse pinkman and saul in
time for the final season of better
called saul the official twitter account
of the series recently revealed this by
posting a photo of the two stars of the
original series it is currently unknown
in what form brian cranston and aaron
paul will celebrate the reunion however
it seems logical to assume that the
first meeting of the odd trio at the
beginning of breaking bad will be
revisited we will find out more when the
sixth season of batter called salt
premieres on april 18th and july 11 2022
as the season will be released in two
parts
what would the jurassic park and
jurassic world movies ever be without
the giant scary dinosaurs in the first
jurassic world it was the indominus rex
that spread fear and terror and in this
sequel it was this somewhat smaller in
the raptor that caused some auction
guests to have a wrecked evening
needless to say jurassic world dominion
will be no exception and will also
introduce a new movie favorite on the
side of the dinosaurs the big change is
that this time it won't be a hybrid
creature but a real dinosaur that
actually existed we are talking about
the gigantic
giganotosaurus that can be seen in a new
image from empire magazine like the
t-rex this dinosaur is a giant carnival
with an estimated length of up to 43
feet it is also believed to be even more
frightening in appearance than the t-rex
as the giganotosaurus is said to be
quite a bit larger director colin
trevorrow compares the animal newcomer
with the joker that wants to see the
world burn at the very least that sounds
like some action-packed encounters
between the protagonists and the new
dinosaur especially since many fans are
looking forward to seeing a real-life
dinosaur and not an imaginary creation
from universal take center stage again
after the two prequels there was also
information about the running time of
the upcoming blockbuster at 2 hours and
26 minutes the new film is by far the
longest installment in the franchise
which should do justice to the
conclusion of the trilogy jurassic world
dominion is expected to hit theaters on
june 10th 2022
[Music]
we have known about the future percy
jackson series from disney plus for
around 2 years now there is some news
about the project because disney casts
13 year old walker scoble who recently
was seen in the atom project alongside
ryan reynolds scoble will play the
titular demigod percy who one day learns
of his kinship to poseidon and the first
part of the book series which forms the
basis for the series percy must stand up
to none other than zeus who suspects the
12 year old of stealing his master bold
the expectations of fans of the book
series are not particularly high after
two mediocre films nevertheless one can
be optimistic for two reasons on the one
hand percy jackson author rick ryden is
creatively involved this time and on the
other hand disney is likely to ensure
that the project gets the necessary
financial support shooting is expected
to begin later this year allowing for a
release date in 2023 we will of course
keep you updated on further news
things are moving forward with a barbie
movie adaption announced a few months
ago after we already heard about the
signing of margot robbies barbie and
ryan gosling as can another hollywood
store has now joined the cast the talk
is of comedian and actor will ferrell
who is to complete this store lineup he
plays the ceo of a toy company and
naturally people suspect that the
company could be mattel sadly there is
no information about the story of the
movie and which is why one can only
speculate some fans would like to see a
similar approach to the lego movie where
different levels of reality are
presented also involve our co-stars
america ferreira simulio and kate
mckinnon we will keep you posted on
further news although an official
release date is not yet known a release
in 2023 seems realistic
this week we would like to suggest you
to watch our news original on the
upcoming thor love and thunder where you
can get all the latest news on the mcu
movie after that you will definitely be
up to date even without a trailer
[Music]
foreign
[Music]